hey guys i'm calling in with a
confession
my work which is subway
okay they've been from the team telling
me to just
change out the expiration date tags and
replace them with ones that are current
and on all the meats and all the
vegetables
and i personally find that [ __ ]
disgusting so anytime my boss isn't
around
i tell the customers about it and they
tell them to get the [ __ ] out
and they usually appreciate it and bugs
and now i'm starting to feel like maybe
i shouldn't do it
because you know i'm probably going to
get fired for it
i'll tell you this brother and i'll tell
you this straight up i used to do this
kind of stuff when poor when i worked at
the grocery
and poor people would come in rich
people would come in i would take their
cereal box and i would scan it like
seven or eight times just for the same
box sure
poor people would come in and i would
just seven or eight boxes i would just
let them go by and not scan them
and you do what you can do and then you
get busted and then you lose your job
now you're out of a job now you're
sucking on the government's tit you're
over there holding one of biden's nuts
you know you're looking for
free boxes right and so now you're
looking for the free box here and so
you know you do what you can you try to
help here and there you know give a
nickel to rand or give a [ __ ] dime to
uh
sharon you know you do what you can but
at a certain point
people who are going to subway still at
this point
in america i understand you're in india
or something you're going to subway
that's a
you know a seven star restaurant you're
going to subway in america you
ain't looking to live forever you
deserve it that's right looking to live
every subway has a bee on the door and
there's usually a roach holding it up
with one of his arms
choosing a few roaches holding it like
this
it is going downhill since jared from
subway sister
allegedly gave me a bj
in the french quarter back in the day
what's up jared
scott yeah prison dog don't worry about
that he liked those four he liked those
four inch rounds baby yeah
yeah and look man at a certain age you
can only mess with six inches or above
maybe
but uh god bless him and god bless
anybody he molested
and um and i'm just saying man you do
what you can but you also you gotta stay
gainfully employed
you do you gotta you gotta do the you
gotta do the work man this is what you
signed up for you do subway was flying
under the radar with these dark hearts
of course the meat's old but if someone
does order the tuna you know that [ __ ]
god foul
there we go i'm gonna get the tuna yeah
don't get the tuna daddy yeah let's
get sick with the tuna if it's a nine
day old cheddar cheese let it fly daddy
but if it's a six-inch tuna
a six-inch tuna that's two weeks old
yeah yeah
you gotta draw the line that's why i
draw the line on the tuna dog
sometimes if you hit him with that tuna
you also maybe hit him with a little uh
antihistamine pill or something that'll
take that edge off maybe some
antibiotics and a foot long yeah hit him
with that z
pack on the back yeah daddy i think
there's ways to combat it you know
hit him with that doxycycline at the end
slipping if you could call
and let your boy know i fancy myself a
foot long meatball
if you just call and let me know if it's
real meat so i can move on with my life
that'd help me out yeah
yeah and so brendan obviously the type
of guy that still eats there no i
haven't been in a long time but i am
craving a meatball
so dude it's not like you're just
craving a ball homie you know what i'm
saying
so what was that guy saying that they
changed the date on the meat yeah
and he warns people and tells him not to
eat there he's doing the lord's work
he's gonna get fired
and i appreciate him but it's also
subway
jared is subway yeah it's tough that
they
like if it's tough that they they
shouldn't allow the sandwiches to be
sold to children i don't think that
should be
it's like vaccines well it's like i
think at that point even
jared uh or whatever isn't
i don't know what his prison nickname is
probably yeah big jerry they call him
big jerry i did hear that he put a lot
of weight back on oh yeah but i heard
that um
i just think if he's getting to put that
still to children
then that's kind of not cool at the very
least they should not allow
the children to have the meats anymore
kids shouldn't even be allowed in subway
let's be honest
is